[Applause]
there they are he is currently running
for governor of california wow and he's
on our show and is the author of san
francisco why progressives ruined city's
michael schellenberger
and he's a columnist for the new york
post and author of the best-selling book
the war on the west how to prevail in
the age of unreasoned douglas murray how
you doing
okay guys
let me start with an impossible question
to ask you we were off last week when
what you're afraid already yeah well
it's impossible so you can't it up
i already said it's impossible no
pressure
uh well the question is this i mean
after that horror unfolded uh there was
first the outrage about availability of
weaponry in america then there was a
second outrage
about the fact that the cops stood
outside and didn't do anything and this
is becoming a pattern in america
parkland
there was a cop there or a security
guard
didn't do his job
the mandalay bay
the guy went up to the wrong floor and
stayed there yeah
what do you do
about people who are paid to act and
just don't how do you solve that problem
because i mean they could take away a
lot of different kinds of guns i mean
i mean this kid was in the room for 40
minutes
before anybody came in it wouldn't have
mattered what kind of gun he had any
kind of gun could do on any amount of
damage in that time what do you do
about law enforcement who don't do their
job
there's the impossible question
yeah
i mean i think there was this initial
reaction that these police officers were
cowardly i don't think we know that i
have to expect that i have to expect
that many of those police officers are
having a hard time sleeping at night
after what's occurred oh i feel bad for
them
well i mean i think they should have a
hard time sleeping yeah although that's
this what the
my concern is that
my concern is that i think when our
institutions fail us
we are so quick to want to shut down the
institutions want to demonize the people
in those institutions yes they got
training the training didn't work
the answer to it is going to be more
training it's going to be to get better
at it we focus on when things go wrong
but things don't things mostly don't go
wrong well we need to we need to learn
from these mistakes it's not
institutions it's people this is not
institutions who didn't run into the
building it's people yeah people didn't
do it yeah that's not an institution and
by the way this is part of the problem
with police training their training is
all about how to preserve their life now
of course we want them to be as safe as
they can but it is a job that entails
danger somewhere they got it into their
head the cops that it's better that i
just
save preserve my health but you're there
to protect and serve us
that's the deal you get to
you know walk tall all the time
everybody kisses your ass
everybody has to comply with you and
then once in a while you just have to
ball up and do the job it's dangerous i
was always told when i came to america
from britain that british people who
speak like me should never talk about
two things abortion guns
uh because we can never understand it
and there is something in that i
actually have
tried very hard to understand and i do
understand why the gun issue exists in
america the people who are very
committed to it who see the second
amendment is an absolutely crucial part
of america freedoms and i understand
their fear always that like the guns are
going to be taken away nevertheless the
same as an outsider it is it's still
inexplicable to me that a guy at the age
of 18 can go into a shop and buy a
battlefield style weapon and he'd have
to wait another three years to buy a
beer in a bar there is
something
just just the first step like the first
step like literally switch those two
things around like let's get used to
beer before we try to get used to
battlefield weapons
yes and the 18 to 21 thing i think is
crucial i mean yes guys we're all guys
we know how stupid we were at asia
right especially men
they mature slower than women
and
not that you're a genius at 21. yeah but
taking those three years away the least
we could do and at the moment there's
this weird route going on again people
saying in congress well people are
allowed to join the military at 18 well
there is every difference in the world
between going into the military getting
the most rigorous training uh getting
your force directed in specific ways and
just handing an 18 year old a gun that
he can use on the american streets there
is every difference but the problem is
you're just always at this stalemate in
this country about this because because
they say like every time some atrocity
like this happens
there's somebody who can say they're
going to take away all of our guns and
then nothing gets nothing gets done
again but as for the police stuff i mean
this is just as you say bill i mean this
has happened again and again
i don't it's hard to judge what you do
in a particular situation but as you say
you know it's their job
to sit in the corridor for 40 minutes
whilst kids are calling and not run in
like i'd have liked to have seen if
there'd have been a bunch of american
mothers with gums in the corridor they'd
have been in there in those seconds
and they were
yeah they were bombed
didn't go in they were mums yes they
were getting arrested by police and
for wanting to go into the school
because job one is always compliance
right with the police yes
you